all right people
this is the live reuben report direct
message
it is october 7th and it's a big day
it's vice presidential debate day here
in america
uh we're going to get to that and and
much more
i'm feeling good today as you can see i
have a fresh haircut
there's nothing that that sort of sets
you right than a fresh haircut
especially in a place like california
where it's unclear
if when you're getting a haircut that
you're doing some sort of criminal act
i'm actually not sure my girl now comes
to my house
and uh we take good care of her we pay
her a little something and we
made her dinner and she cut my hair and
she cut david's hair
she offered actually to cut the dog's
whiskers we didn't do that
but i'm feeling good there's a lot going
on in the world
and let's get to it so you know when i
started this thing i always said to you
guys you know we're gonna do mostly two
or three stories two or three stories a
day
we're actually gonna do three stories
today but i am gonna throw in a clip
right up front from this lunatic nut bag
bill de blasio who is the mayor
of new york city who is basically ruined
new york city
um the amount of people leaving new york
city is absolutely insane i have a
friend
who lives in new york city who's still
in new york city he's stuck there
because he he owns a business at least
for now
that's in new york city uh but he's been
telling me that his building
basically which was always because it
was in a pretty decent area and decent
prices for the apartment
it was always jam-packed in a waiting
list to actually get an apartment in his
building
an apartment for rent um that his
building is at about 60
um open vacancies right now uh
when you add that to the fact that my my
sister my actual sister not jennifer
rubin my actual sister and her husband
and two kids left new york city
i've mentioned to you guys before i've
had family members in new york city
since we attracted at one point to the
early 1900s probably around 1908
at times there were about 60 family
members in the different boroughs
there's one person left
i think a few weeks ago i said that
there were zero people but there is one
distant cousin
left in new york city crime is way up
you may have seen the video of rick
moranis getting assaulted
on the upper west side i used to live
right there if you didn't see this so
rick moranis is the actor from
ghostbusters remember rick moranis and
uh
any you know honey i shrunk the kids and
a whole bunch of other stuff anyway
um he actually got out of acting for
about 20 years
until a few weeks ago he was in a
commercial i mean i used to see him on
the upper west all the time
and i think he had a son who was very
ill so i usually if i see people that i
like what they do i usually say hi but i
sensed that the guy really wanted a
private life
but i used to see him wandering all
around the upper west and he got just
assaulted randomly
by some guy literally on one of the
streets that i would see him on all the
time so i assume it's pretty close to
where he lives
but violence is uh murder is up you know
we're seeing the stores be attacked and
everything else so this this de blasio
guy who wants to defund the police and
he's just sort of the worst
sort of like progressive just everything
will get worse under my watch but it's
never my fault
type of politician he put out this video
on twitter
about masks and and well just
watch for yourself
[Music]
i'm not making this an anti-mask thing
we've been through this before when i go
into stores i follow whatever their
policies are
i put on the mask yada yada my guys when
they work here in my house we don't wear
masks
i have friends over we don't wear masks
everyone is allowed to make whatever
decisions they want in their own life
at least for now but this this like
fetishizing of it this is what new
yorkers do you know before you de blasio
new yorkers were known for having a
pretty
uh intense independence streak and just
watching oh just i don't like bill de
blasio in case that's not clear all
right
let's get to the uh the big three
stories so the story is obviously i'm
gonna do some uh vp debate
predictions and preview we're gonna
start with that so i'll get to that
momentarily
then here in california gavin newsom
who's the
he's the bill de blasio of california uh
he has instituted california health
equity
metrics equity metrics and every time
you hear the word equity
bells should go off in your head because
in essence we're going to start looking
at race
uh when it comes to covid numbers and
then
in essence okay we want the races to be
equal
as to who's getting covered so kind of
like
you might want more people with more
white people with covid so
that it matches the amount of black
people that covet or asian people at
covet or something it's like this has
nothing to do with race
but progressives inject race into
everything so why not into cobit
and then the third story i want to talk
about is the nba
ratings drop which are cataclysmic
absolutely disastrous for the league and
and just a moment about two minutes
before we started this
i just saw a tweet that uh from outkick
that's
clay travis's site and they do great
sports coverage
actual sports coverage you're not going
to believe it if you like sports
it's not like turning on espn where
you're watching politics
they cover sports weird and
uh they had a story they're running a
story about how adam silver who is the
commissioner of the nba
is saying that there will be less social
justice on the court
uh this season because the ratings i'll
get to more of the numbers
when we hit the story but the nba finals
ratings
are down if i'm remembering it correctly
i will check in a moment
down 55 from last year
that is unbelievable and last year was
down from the year before
everyone's trapped at home right now and
there was an interesting exchange
between ted cruz who's a huge nba fan
you may remember that from when i
interviewed him a couple months back
and mark cuban who of course uh owns the
dallas mavericks they had a really
interesting exchange
about the ratings drop on the twitter
machine
and we're going to throw up some of the
tweets and we'll discuss what's going on
there
all right so let's talk about the vp
debate first
now i think the most important thing is
to realize because
again the media which makes everything
absolutely hysterical
is going to try to pretend that if
someone wins the debate tonight whatever
wins means
that that really nudges an election one
way or another now just
back out for a second and think back
to barack obama
and joe biden who was his vice president
think back to al gore as the vp for bill
clinton think back to dick cheney
for george w bush think back to dan
quayle for george h.w bush i mean just
go back as far as you want
and generally speaking vice presidents
don't have
a tremendous amount of influence they
don't have a tremendous amount that
they're actually doing uh i mean
look at mike pence he hasn't really done
that much he's done some cobid stuff but
you know i think partly he's just there
to
to steady the ship i'll get to more of
that in just a sec but generally
speaking
very very very few people actually make
their
decision uh related to the vice
president now
i actually think that could be a little
bit different this year because
first off you just have to look at the
age of these two guys doesn't matter who
you like joe biden is 77
years old 77 years old and he and he
obviously has some cognitive stuff right
like
it was a miracle the way he pulled
through on the debate and even in the
days since then
uh he's had a whole bunch of other
strange gaffes that you don't see on
mainstream media but you see him on
twitter
and and elsewhere so he's 77 and and
even if you're a huge biden supporter
i suspect that you probably you probably
know that right so that's
that's one thing um now
trump is 74 years old trump is obviously
a bit overweight
trump also just had covid remember that
now apparently he's feeling better than
he
felt in 20 years and i'm sure they they
pumped him full of all the stuff
whatever the stuff is and they haven't
fully released all of that
but the simple fact is he's 74 years old
so you got a 74 year old running against
a 77 year old
so in essence unlike other years past i
think there is a little more reason
to to look at the health to think about
the health of these two guys and then go
okay so then who are the people behind
them in this case
uh former indiana governor mike pence
and former attorney general here in
california
uh kamala harris so for pence i think
it's it's sort of like this pence
basically
all he has to do pretty much is not fall
out of his chair
and he's he's a pretty stiff guy right
like he's pretty controlled composed
you're not gonna break him
he's not gonna he's not gonna go over
the top he's not going to try to get
you in a big way all he all his job i
think is in essence is for
for whatever that slew of people that
are like kind of in the trump space
but they think oh he's a little erratic
you don't know what he's going to do
he's slightly bananas the tweeting the
whole thing
trump um pence is basically like the
he's the guy steadying the ship he's
just the guy that sits back there and
you go oh there's something
kinda decent there you may not like all
of his policies
um so be it but like he's really just
there for that
and i think the proof of that is that
you know he's really made no noise
in these couple years right there's not
any stories about him doing anything
crazy or doing anything behind trump's
back
or wanting to usurp power or anything
like that like
he's just been there and been studying
so his job i think is to just have an
hour and a half
where he doesn't let the thing get
completely derailed
and i think he'll probably do that right
like i just think
there's there's not much excitement
there
it is what it is you got to just you
know look like you could do the job if
you needed to do it
for kamal harris it's a little bit
different because
i think there's a lot of reason to
believe that she will have a
far far far bigger role as a vice
president than certainly
than mike pence does but then generally
vice presidents would have right like
there's a lot of reason
to think that biden is not necessarily
up to this that the party installed her
and remember
the thing about the party picking her or
biden picking her or the clinton machine
or the obama machine picking her however
she got picked
by the dnc it was a it was a really odd
move
because kamala harris when when the
first debate happened the first
democratic debate most people thought
she won
a lot of people said she was going to be
the nominee and then quickly as people
got to know her more and more
through a couple of debates and some
public stuff people realized that they
didn't really like her
and when i say people i'm talking about
her own party and then she was out quick
so remember
buddha judge and uh elizabeth warren
and bernie and the rest of them andrew
yang even
tulsi they all stayed until super
tuesday and then they all dropped out on
the same day and there was obviously
some shenanigans back
you know backdoor shenanigans were in
effect they were saying you're all going
to
back out right now and back biden and
that's the way the party's going and
we'll take care of you on the back end
right like you'll you'll
get a job or something like that kamala
didn't even make it that far she was
out already at that point so that means
that the base of the party
right this has nothing to do with
republicans conservatives anyone else
the base of the party that's voting
in the primaries they did not like her
so you could argue in essence she's not
left enough for the bernie elizabeth
warren
crowd um and actually she doesn't really
like biden either i mean she in effect
called bite and racist
in you know that's what everyone's
racist but you know she in effect called
biden racist
in one of the debates and there's a
moment that i've quoted a couple of
times that i think is so telling it's a
it's a perfectly telling moment
during one of the debates when she was
still in it and
they asked joe biden or they ask kamala
about using an executive action on guns
meaning can the
can the office of the presidency do
something
create a law that would override the
other branch of government right
to create a law that would restrict one
of our
god-given rights one of the things
enshrined in the bill of rights which is
the second amendment
and biden jumped in first and he said
well it would have to be
constitutional and she kamala harris
with that with that wicked laugh she
laughed in his face and she said
joe can't we just say yes we can
and it's like all right that that's a
pretty scary moment so i think there's
an authoritarian tendency
by kamala and she's put a lot of people
in jail in california for weed even
though she's admitted to smoking weed
i've never put anyone in jail for weed
i've smoked weed might even smoked it a
couple days ago
okay it's legal here now people come for
me would you
um but but so in essence though
there's a lot of stuff that she has to
kind of clean up because
she's not totally in line with joe but
enough i would say but she's certainly
not totally in line with the radical
portion of the base that definitely
would have wanted bernie
or or elizabeth warren um and she's got
to sort of arbitrage those things right
she's got to figure out how to
balance those things back and forth and
on top of it she has to figure out a way
to look presidential in case biden just
flames out so i think she's under more
pressure than pence's
pence just has to continue to make sure
it looks like you know if something
happened to trump
covet whatever like if if he couldn't do
it anymore
or whatever that that he would be okay
so i don't expect any major
fireworks it might get a little hostile
i guarantee you
no matter what happens that the
headlines tomorrow
will be about um you know pence's toxic
masculinity while talking to a woman and
his
uh his racist attitude or the rest of it
so we know that's what the mainstream
media focuses on and
where they frame everything and you just
gotta just break their framing and if
you break their framing it's a lot
easier to understand
but again at the end of the day not many
people's votes
will be moved by a vp debate and
what this all always comes down to
especially in these last couple weeks is
we got the hardcores on both sides no
doubt about it
what what is that group in the middle
how big is it what you know it's not
even middle really
the undecided person right now who
really isn't sure what they're gonna do
are they gonna vote third party are they
gonna stay home are they gonna
you know begrudgingly vote one way or
another way
that's the group and and i don't know
that anyone has good numbers
on how many of those people there are i
suspect they're a lot
and i and as i've been saying i suspect
most of those people
will break towards trump but we shall
see
um all right let's move on any oh by the
way i will be doing
a uh live stream tonight uh
after the debate immediately after the
debate which will be 7 30
pacific time that's uh 10 30 eastern
time i'll be doing
uh solo debate wrap up
for about half hour 45 minutes and then
i'm jumping on over with uh
glenn beck on the blaze and i'm actually
quite thrilled to tell you guys that
when i did my debate wrap
up last week or was it about 10 days ago
now
we got about 700 000 views on that thing
and it it's just me and i got my
producer michael here and clyde the dog
and i'm just telling you what i think in
real time and we got about 700 000 views
and that was more than than most of
our are sort of comparable well
certainly the youtube channels but even
some of the big networks so
i don't know i guess i guess trying to
say something in a halfway decent way
and not trying to you know make you want
to jump out your windows is working for
people so i appreciate the support on
that
let's go to the second story because
gavin newsom and this guy's a real piece
of work right
uh just an endless piece of work we're
watching the state just kind of crumble
homelessness everywhere drug use
everywhere he was the governor of
uh sorry he was the mayor of san
francisco and we all know what happened
to san francisco i mean the last time i
was in san francisco i saw several
people
doing drugs on the street i've told you
a million times there's literally an
app that will tell you where human feces
is you know you've done something wrong
if you need an app for that right
he destroyed san francisco but what
happens in california you fail your way
up so he is the governor
here now and what they're trying to do
is institute a california health
equity metrics program related to covid
because they've seen some disparities in
ethnic background in essence color of
skin
and and who's being affected by kobe now
first off before i'm going to read some
of it to you
but before i do that i want to make it
very very clear very very very very
very very very very very clear that
i in no way want any group of people
to have more covid than any other group
of people i would like
our government whether it's our federal
government or our state government or
our city government
to do the best they can to help
everybody equally
and maybe there are certain places
that through education or because they
live on top of each other in giant
high-rises or whatever it might be
that there are certain spots that might
need more help or different help or all
of those things
the question is is the government
suitable uh
to deal with these things and
unfortunately in california you know we
have a government that just takes a ton
of money but doesn't do a lot with it
and and this is one of the things that i
can never understand you have all of
these people i mean everyone in
california is like wait a minute our
schools suck our roads suck there's
homelessness everywhere
and they don't seem to equate that with
oh we've had one party
running this place forever they it seems
in many cases they somehow associate
that with trump
who's only been president for three
months and isn't running california
so it's a little bit of a of a
disconnect i think in the reality on the
ground and everything else
but to be very clear i don't want
black people getting covered i don't
want white people getting covered i
don't want asian people getting it
straight people
gay people trans people anything else i
want nobody to have kovid
but what happens is and this is why
social justice is so
pernicious we start looking at
everything
through the lens of racial equity
not equality that the outcomes should
all be the same
and then that starts racializing
everything and you guys know that
everything has been racialized so
there is a document that has been put
out by our california authorities i'm
just going to
read a little bit of it it is called a
blueprint for a safer economy
equity focus equity focus okay and i'll
just read
two portions of it it's a long document
it has been clearly documented
documented that certain communities
low-income black latino pacific islander
and essential workers
have been disproportionately impacted by
covid19
in terms of higher rates of infection
hospitalizations and deaths
these disparities create a public health
imperative to address
exposure in all communities including
those
disproportionately impacted as a measure
to protect all communities so
that sort of doesn't sound that terrible
right there's
certain communities and they lay them
out black
pacific islander et cetera that seems to
be having bigger spikes
in covid and that then could affect all
communities that actually sounds
kind of okay because we would want to
see well if we're seeing a certain
area like a physical area or a small
community that has a certain outbreak we
would want to look at that and say okay
let's see what we can do to fix that but
it goes on
and lays out an equity metric not an
equality metric an equity metric
and this is for a county with a
population of greater than 106
000. the county must ensure that the
test positivity rates
in its most disadvantaged neighborhoods
as defined by being in the lowest
quartile of the health places index
census tracts
do not significantly lag behind its
overall
county test positivity rate as described
in detail below
now this is where it gets a little bit
weird because the implication there is
oh
let's say we have one group that has you
know higher rates of covid
and let's say we have this other group
that doesn't right well why not just
if we just move resources out of this
community that's doing okay and put it
here
well maybe that'll get push this down
but maybe it'll push this up and this is
what i would say
is sort of the the second order of
things that
the the progressives are not very good
at looking at like this
this sort of sounds right that we should
we should be going to certain areas and
helping people in
in certain ways like it kind of does
sound right but but what they're really
in essence saying is if only we could
get it
so that the exact amount of white people
had the exact amount of covet as the
exact amount of black people
and that really doesn't make sense you
want nobody to have it and you want
policies that will ensure that nobody
has it and you want to give people
proper information
and that really is why i wanted to do
this story because what this really does
come down to
is proper information and as i talked
about yesterday you know they
they put up this silly silly like just
profoundly silly
um one of these graphic charts that they
put up there
which shows you that when you're going
out to eat with your own family
you should chew put the mask on and then
take the mask off and chew again
and it's like these are crazy things and
why should we trust
that these that the people in charge
know what they're doing i think that
really is becoming the bigger problem
and this is not something that's
specific
to california alone let's not forget
that nashville tennessee the daily wire
just moved over to tennessee they just
moved to nashville
there was a big scandal all the
mainstream media dropped it pretty
quickly
where the mayor's office in effect was
hiding the covid numbers because they
were so low that they didn't feel it
would allow them to keep the lockdown
happening
so you know so many of the things that
that
that i will talk about here that i do
talk about and we'll continue to talk
about
are not necessarily the the policies
themselves as if they are so important
but it's the way the media frames
everything
and what they cover and what they don't
and and we've got to figure out a
a better way to get information to
people but but
equity but anytime you hear the word
equity not equality
i want equality for everyone i want
everyone
to have equal access to things and equal
laws and all of those things but
equity meaning that the outcome should
be exactly the same
is really really dangerous because once
you start doing that
right if you had if you had equal
equity in any job you'd be saying okay
then we're gonna hire more of these
people to help these
people but what you are doing is
punishing these people unjustly i have
no desire
to punish someone based on the color of
their skin i have no desire to punish
someone
based on their sexuality i am as
inclined to hire a straight white guy
as i would a black lesbian i don't care
about those things so
it's can you do your job and to prove
that we just hired a new director here
at the reuben report who will be
starting with us in about 10 days
and i'm not going to name all of this
person's immutable characteristics but i
assure you they did not come up
in our hiring process we got about 500
emails
and not once did me or anyone on my team
or my business managers looking through
them go oh
what well what sexuality are they what
gender
are they what color are they that in the
old days would be called bigotry
but now we call it tolerance because
we're a confused people and we need help
speaking of confused people needing help
i want to do this third story on the nba
ratings you guys have heard me talk
about this million times
i am a huge basketball fan i love
basketball
when i play basketball it's like the one
time really that i can shut my brain off
and not think about all of this stuff
i just basketball to me is like
happiness and joy i started watching
the nba around 88 89 it was right at the
end of like
you know the great lakers celtics stuff
the the bad boy pistons
were getting good at the time i was you
know at my peak years where all those
were the jordan bulls years and all that
stuff and as i've told you a million
times when i do cardio now those are the
games
that i watch i just finished watching
all of the 92 the original dream team
games i love basketball i love watching
it i love playing it everything else
i did not watch a minute of the nba this
season
because they've politicized everything
when you watch an nba game it says black
lives matter on the court
black lives matter is a marxist
organization that has all sorts of bad
stuff on their own website like taking
down the nuclear family
and that has nothing to do with do i
think black people's lives matter which
of course i do and i think white
people's lives matter
and i think straight people's lives
matter and christian lives matter
and the rest of it it is a political
organization and a political message
that has been injected into the game and
then
of course every time you turn on espn
they're doing politics
they're not doing sports although i will
say in in one
defense of the nba uh nba on tnt which
is you know ernie johnson
and shaq and kenny smith and charles
barkley
i actually have not watched any of that
this season either but i do see clips
occasionally on twitter and barkley
is pretty fantastic when it comes to
calling out all of this nonsense and you
know barkley
who's always been outspoken and you may
remember back in around 91 92
there was this big thing he did a
commercial for i think it was nike
saying i'm not a role model people were
very angry at him for that
and i think he is a role model now
whether he likes it or not because the
guy
the guy has an ability to to fight the
mob and say things that are true and
and just i saw this clip just a week or
so ago where he was talking about how
you know all these people saying defund
the police well these are usually
white liberals uh not to use identity
politics but these are usually white
liberals who are saying defund the
police and what does that do it then
harms
you know black urban communities like
again it's like you don't think about
the second order of things it sounds
kind of right
next thing you know you've got more
crime and more drug use and more murder
and everything else which by the way is
exactly what's happening in minneapolis
and new york city and portland and
seattle
and all of these places like across the
board people across the board
so anyway the nba ratings have dropped
unbelievably
uh fast this year so the ratings right
now
are down 55 from last year
55 okay that's more than half obviously
i'm not a math magician
but that's more than half down 55
percent and i saw another incredible
statistic
that they're down 70 since the last time
lebron was in the finals so lebron's on
the lakers now
uh and he is in the finals this year he
was in the finals couple years ago with
cleveland
and it's down 70 since then you cannot
tell me that that doesn't have something
to do
with politics people have just had it
people have just
had it why do you watch these things you
watch them
so that you can see great elite athletes
do things that you can't do and you can
escape
the the mundane life um you know that's
what sports is all about you don't watch
it so that
the guy with the back of you know on the
back of his jersey social justice
warrior 41
throws the aliyu pass to the patriarchy
and he dunks on wokester 9.
like you don't do it for that and and
for me it's like i'll watch old games
and that's enough and i'll shoot around
with my friends and play horse
and that's enough i think these you know
the idea that
people that in many cases are making
millions and millions and millions of
dollars i mean lebron try to imagine
the incredible amount of wealth that
lebron has which by the way
i think he deserves i think it's great
that he can make that money in america
and
and do whatever he wants to do with that
money um and
by the way say whatever he wants to say
right i'm not telling lebron not to say
it but there
are consequences and i think they're
seeing the consequences of it so as i
said at the beginning of this
right before we started i saw something
on on outkick which again is clay
travis's
uh website where they actually do sports
and he's got jason whitlock over there
who left
fox sports news for it and they just ran
a story about how david silver who is
the nba commissioner
has basically said there's going to be
less social justice on the court so
you just have to think about it this way
now he was all big on it but now it's
like he's looking at the numbers and
going
i guess social justice doesn't matter as
much and that's how you know it's kind
of nonsense because if it really
mattered
then he wouldn't care about the ratings
if this really was about systemic
and evil spreading throughout society he
would do what is right and keep the
messages there
but now it's actually destroying his
product and the league that
that these incredible athletes and and
the guy before him david stern built and
he's going okay
okay i'm looking at it we're gonna have
to scale some of this back anyway i
mentioned all of this because then i saw
a really interesting interaction
between senator ted cruz who is a huge
nba fan i had him on the show he told me
an incredible story if you didn't see
our interview he told me a fantastic
story
about how he was on a plane once and
hakeem elijah
who is i think the best center in nba
history
uh came onto the plane and uh
ted cruz wanted him to sign something
and ted cruz obviously a senator from
texas elijah played with the rockets
houston
and all he had was his copy of on
liberty by john stuart mill
so uh elijah signed his copy of on
liberty i just think that's a fantastic
story anyway
ted cruz got into it on twitter with
mark cuban i'm going to throw up a
couple tweets here and then i i jumped
in on it
at the end um and it started with this
cruise by
this tweet by ted cruz which says not
surprising personally speaking this is
the first time in years that i haven't
watched
a single nba game in the finals and as
you can see he linked
to an article on hannity.com that shows
that the nba finals was watched
by less than five million people and
that game three was the least
watched in recorded ratings history
okay so that's kind of interesting so
then mark cuban jumped in on it mark
cuban's the the billionaire
uh from shark tank and he owns the
dallas mavericks which is an nba team
and he said a u.s senator with three nba
teams in his state
employing thousands of people and he is
rooting for their businesses to do
poorly
this is who you are ted cruz every
minute of your life
this is exactly who you are now
he wasn't rooting for it he's saying why
he doesn't want to watch it he's not
rooting for people to be fired that's
obvious and cuban's tweet is over the
top
cruz responded i love the houston
rockets and have rooted for them my
entire life i happily cheer for the
spurs and mavericks against any
non-texas team
but mark cuban the nba is get engaged in
a concerted effort to one
insult their fans and turn and two turn
every game into a left-wing
political lecture that's dumb and then
this is the one that i had to respond to
because cuban
really lost it here he said you are so
full of [ __ ]
you haven't watched a game of the finals
how would you know what is being said or
done
since when is a desire to end racism and
insult to anyone or political
and you don't think using hashtag get
woke go broke is a partisan
insult again this is who you are now
first off just real quick
the the go woke go broke thing
well that's obvious we know it's
happening everywhere right espn's
ratings are collapsing all of these
companies that
allow wokeness to go in their businesses
crumble so that's not partisan
that's just a fact you let social
justice in and and it destroys your
organization
the part that i had to respond to was
that that um
when cuban said this is a desire to end
racism that that's what this is about
so i had to jump in on it and i tweeted
to uh to mark
it's not a desire to end racism it's a
desire to mainstream it through
infecting every part of public life
i also didn't watch one minute of the
nba this season and i've been a huge fan
since 88-89
so i think this is part the reason i
wanted to do this is not to show you
little twitter drama but it's to show
you how we're all sort of telling
ourselves our own story so i'll i'll not
impugn
mark cuban's motives here i'm going to
assume that he actually really believes
that the black lives matter movement
and this whole thing is about ending
racism like i i'll i'll go out there and
and
and say that he believes that maybe he
doesn't and it's more nefarious but
i'll go with that right and what i was
trying to say to him and i didn't say it
i wasn't being a dick i wasn't being
mean i was trying to
show him actually it's not about that
but people are sick of everything being
you know construed as racist and putting
racism everywhere where it shouldn't be
he didn't respond and
and i suspect he's not going to change
his opinion on this
um but you know as you can see this was
another example of ted cruz was being
was being purely professional there
there was nothing he wasn't attacking
anybody personally and everything else
mark human comes in with you're full of
[ __ ] and unfortunately that does seem to
be the asymmetry
of the arguments these days that one
side does seem to want to talk about
ideas a little bit more the other side
kind of wants the insult it's just how
it is all right people
that is the direct message for today
hope you feel
a little saner that you got a little
something that maybe you can bring to
the dinner table or to
a conversation with a friend or a
co-worker that that maybe
will make things not feel as crazy i
will be live
right here on the youtube tonight at 7
30 pacific time that's 10 30
eastern time right at the end of the
debate we might start a minute or two
early uh just to get the jump uh
so you can if you're not subscribed or
if you've been unsubscribed because i
get a lot of that make sure you're
subscribed you can click that
notification bell and you'll be notified
thanks for watching we'll be back
tonight and then we'll be back tomorrow
and who knows what happens the day after
that
you